thank you
[Music]
yep
hello once again and welcome to I'd like
to know our Biblical question and answer
program the program we get to answer
your questions where we get to hear from
you to hear what is on your mind in your
heart and we get to search the word of
God to try to find answers for you from
the word of God we promise as always to
do that if an answer can be found in the
word of God we will find it and we will
make it available to you and we thank
you for your participation we really
thank you for sending in questions
because without those questions we would
have no program but it gives us an
opportunity to do something that we like
to do and that is study the word of God
my name is CA Murray and I'm in the
company of uh fellow speaker here at um
secret Sunset and some TV Pastor Daniel
Miranda and Pastor is always good to
have you here with us amen it's always
good to be here especially with you
sharing this program together praise the
Lord Pastor Bohr is not with us today we
usually try to keep the triumvirate
together but he is out doing the work of
the Lord he is ministering and we are
left to carry on in his stead but we
miss him always because we like his
input and um we we like to have have him
here uh to add
salt and light to our answers in our
discussion we have a number of questions
today uh again let me encourage you that
should you like to be part of this
experience should you want to set into
question we encourage you to do so and
you can do so by sending your questions
to TV at some
tv.org that is TV at some
s-u-m-tv.org and we will add your
questions to our pile we will get to
your questions just as soon as we can if
you don't hear it the first or the
second week stay with us we're getting
to them because our pile is impressive
and it is a long pile but we are working
our way down and working our way through
and as you can note we don't rush
through any question we try to take our
time with them you take the time to
write them we want to take the time to
answer them fully from the word of God
so we
encourage you send in your questions and
we will get to them past Pastor I'm
going to pray
and then
if you could go to this first question
which is a holdover from last week's
program uh because Isaac
from Zimbabwe asked one two three
questions and we didn't get a chance to
finish the last two so we'll take a look
at at those before we we move on father
God again we praise you and thank you
for the privilege of study your word is
indeed a lamp unto our feet amen and a
light that shines on the path before us
in that word we have safety we know your
good will we know you're away for us we
have your presence we have your power we
have your Providence we know that you
are in your word and that you exalt this
word above your name so Lord please
teach us this day those things that you
would have us to know and then help us
to put them into practice and to study
to show ourselves approved from the word
of God we thank you in Jesus name amen
amen amen
so we're continuing with Isaac niambia
from Zimbabwe in our last program we
answered the first question and the
second one in regards to the rich men
and Lazarus on the state of the Dead
and now he asked the final question
and this one is in regards to
Genesis chapter
4 verse 10 and the blood of Abel crying
out from the ground so the Bible says
here in Genesis 4 10 maybe pastors
Pastor Murray could read that and also
Hebrews chapter 11 verse 4. I can read
Hebrews 11 verse 4. okay Genesis chapter
4 verse 10 reading from the new King
James and he said what have you done
that is the Lord speaking the voice of
your brother's blood cries out to me
from the ground
and Hebrews 11 4
the Bible says by faith Abel offered to
God a more excellent sacrifice than Cain
through which he obtained witness that
he was righteous God testifying of his
gifts and through it he being dead still
speaks okay he didn't he being dead
still speaks
so the question is
um
what does that mean
the the blood of Abel cries from the
ground and that he being dead still
speaks you know
um the Bible is its own best interpreter
yes and if you stay with it long enough
it's going to give you an answer to your
question if you superimpose the answer
found in Hebrews chapter 11 verse 4 on
to Genesis 4 verse 10 you get the answer
to your question that the that he being
dead yet speaketh or still speaks
um the the the untimely death the is
crying for event is is crying for
justice this is the word I want to put
it's crime for justice which is what it
means when it says in verse 10 of
Genesis 4 your your your the voice of
your brother's blood yes cries out to me
from the ground so the The Entity if I
can use it that way that is crying for
justice is the blood blood of your
brother which was untimely spilled and
you see that all the way down in Hebrews
chapter 11 verse 4. you know you stay
with the Bible long enough it's going to
give you the answer and it's going to
give you the answer that you need yes
exactly so so even the Hebrews 11 4
makes clear that this is not
able soul that is speaking or or that he
is alive but he says he's dead but he's
still speaking how well through the
blood as we read in Genesis chapter 4
why the blood well in Leviticus 17 verse
11 it says that the that the life is in
the life is in the blood so this is a
figurative way of saying his life is
asking for justice correct it's another
way and actually this was a common
language in biblical times because Jesus
also used it when Jesus pronounced the
walls upon the Pharisees in in Matthew
23 let me read a few texts from this
chapter Matthew 23 and now he's uh
pronouncing judgments upon the scribes
and Pharisees for all the matters of of
the Old Testament times it says here
uh verses 34 and 35 therefore indeed I
send you prophets wise man describes
some of them you will kill and crucify
some of them you will discourage in your
synagogues and persecute from City to
city that on you may come all the
righteous blood shed on the Earth
from the blood of righteous Abel to the
blood of Zechariah actually the son of
Jehovah who you murder between the
temple and the altar you know Ellen
White Builds on this
and she comments in the book of Desire
of Ages that when Jesus pronounced these
words
he pointed to the blood of Zechariah
that was still spilled on some of the
stones in the temple yes he had not been
erased yes yes as a as a witness of the
condemnation that would come to the
nation if they would not repent so
Zechariah was not crying out himself no
but the blood was there as a testimony
right right you know when when you're
doing exegesis or you're trying to find
out what the Bible is saying there there
are three or four questions you need to
ask one who said it uh that's their
background their training
um what are the actual words that were
said then you need to ask what did he
mean because sometimes you say something
but it means something else like I say
well Daniel is out to lunch you know
um in in in in modern slang that means
he's he's not quite on his game he's a
little off his rocker you know but
you're saying he's out to lunch but has
nothing to do with lunch it has to do
with mental capacity yes
um so
um and I apologize for using your name
so that's what was said what did it mean
then the second the third thing is what
did the audience take it to me in other
words the people that are being spoken
to how did they take it
um did they take it literally did they
take it figuratively figuratively like
the parable that we're talking about in
the last program it wasn't understood to
be literal and this is not understood to
be to be literal it is figurative uh and
then you make application yes but unless
you go through those steps those
processes you may come up with a an
errant sort of answer because you've got
to ask all of those questions to get the
correct correct that is correct and that
is the same sense of the of the word and
the expression that we find the fifth
seal that actually in a summer school
lesson yeah we're studying that and we
highly recommend that you watch our
discussion on the Sabbath school lesson
we go deeper into into these difficult
texts but in Revelation chapter 6 verses
9 through 11 we read about the souls and
those who have been slain for the word
of God and for the testimony in which
they held and they were under the Altar
and it says that they were crying how
long Lord holy and true until you judge
and avenge our blood on those who dwell
on the earth so does the blood speak
little really
no it does not so this is figuratively a
way of saying of crying out for justice
and for vengeance yes yes praise the
Lord okay
we are
moving along
okay what do you have as the next
question Daniel
Colin Marshall
there we go
all right Colin Marsh do you want to
read that the the little question yep
okay so calling is is writing from the
United Kingdom the UK yes indeed
wonderful that we have some audience
there too actually we have a channel a
free-to-air channel in the UK yes indeed
you can also watch our programs there
uh it says hello again in the new King
James version and several other versions
The Greek ionis is translated worlds
that is commonly quoted as biblical
evidence that there are other worlds
which are in inhabited in some form or
another
in other versions it is variously
translated World universe
but my understanding is that ionis is
better understood as Aeons or ages
example relating to time epochs rather
than other worlds
a minority of English translations like
the
young
W excuse me y l t
forgot that what the L is
do use ages
could you help please so the question is
what's the best translation for
is it worlds or is it ages and is it
correct to use those texts
to say that there are other worlds so
those are the basically the two
questions here she get right to the
answer I I lean on the director of of
Ages
um
to try to use these texts to prove other
worlds I think it's a little thin it's a
bit of a stretch
um it's it's much more accurate to to
use it uh as ages
um of course we see it in Revelation and
and in other places but I I I'm I I come
down on the side of Ages more than than
other worlds and I agree with you
actually that's that's actually the best
translation ages
and we find in the Bible for the word
Cosmos which is the world the word for
World World
um we have we actually see the
difference in the Bible in the way these
two words are being used for example in
Matthew 13 verse 49 so Jesus says here
so shall it be at the end of the world
the word there is ionos which is at the
end of the age at the end of time
but in Matthew 16 verse
Jesus says what is it a man profited if
he shall gain the whole world
and lose his own soul so now here here
this is talking about our world Cosmos
is the work here it's not ionis yes but
it's it's Cosmos and we have different
examples and Matthew 18 verse 7 woe unto
the world because of offenses for he
must needs that offenses come
again this is talking about the world
our world but again we find the word
ionis in Matthew
[Music]
um
chapter
actually yeah let me see here
um in Matthew chapter 24 verse 21 here
again I I meant to say Cosmos for then
shall be Great Tribulation such as was
not since the beginning of the world to
this time no nor ever shall be so I
agree with Colin that this is the best
translation uh to the world ionis and
there are better ways to prove that
there are other worlds
for example I have just a simple a
simple example in Revelation chapter 12
we read
verse
12 Revelation chapter 12 verse 12
therefore Rejoice O heavens and you who
dwell in them notice it says Heavens in
plural yes what the inhabitants of the
earth and the Sea for the devil has come
down to you having great breath because
he knows that he has a short time so so
if the heavens and those who dwell in
them
is is being brought up in contrast to
the inhabitants of the earth so these
Heavens in plural must refer to other
worlds yes yes yes and there are other
places in job and other places of the
Bible where there's indication that
there are intelligent life there is
certain intelligent life on other worlds
and um
uh those texts established it much more
firmly than trying to use uh uh these
texts to do so uh it's just it's a
little it's a little thin you gotta do a
little dancing to try to make it to make
it fit and it does not fit so Colin
thank you so very much from
Salisbury in the United Kingdom we
appreciate your writing and thank you
for your your question
all right
Brian I think is the next one yes Brian
ooh m m with sigua
M with sigua uh I'd like to know what
country in Africa Brian is from but uh
thank you Brian for for writing to us
um let's see I'm confused by the way the
concept of spirit is used in the Bible
in Genesis chapter 2 verse 7 the breath
that God breathed into man is referred
to as the spirit
and when I read in Genesis in Galatians
in Galatians 5 18 it talks about being
led by the spirit
when I saw Spirit capitalized I thought
this was referring to the Holy Spirit
interestingly interestingly when I
looked up the Greek word for Spirit uh
the texts in Galatians it said it's
pneuma which means breath
that confused me so how can
breath lead us whenever spirit is
mentioned in the Bible
it seems uh in the Bible if it is not
referring to the Holy Spirit does it
always mean breath and he thanks us okay
well let's see uh a couple of things
here
um
when I read Galatians it talks about
being led by the spirit that of course
is the holy spirit
um and he's referring to Galatians
chapter 5 verse 18.
um
when I saw Spirit as capitalized uh it
was referring to the Holy Spirit and and
it should be sometimes you see Spirit
capitalized in in versions of the Bible
and not capitalized capitalized in
others but you but when the Bible is
speaking about the Holy Spirit it is it
is always on universally capitalized
um you have ruach and you have pneuma uh
you have Hebrew and Greek uh the the
idea is the same nowhere do you have an
idea of a conscious entity leaving or
entering exiting or entering entering
the body and I think that is what uh is
important uh when it talks about the
Breath of God uh which animates the body
as opposed to the Holy Spirit which
which gives us uh spiritual life exactly
yeah some people have the idea that the
the holy spirit is a disembodied entity
because the the word Spirit we think of
that as as a spirit something ethereal
something that doesn't have a shape or a
form
but that's not the case it is true that
the same word that is used for breath
is also used for the spirit in the
Hebrew ruak in the Greek pneuma it is it
is both the same now what is the
relationship between that well the Holy
Spirit
for example in Genesis 2 7 that he
quotes he breathed into his nostrils the
breath of life you know
the holy spirit is the agent that
participated in the creation giving life
but uh so the breadth of Life the breath
can be
in other words the breath is used as
ruak or pneuma but at the same time this
spirit that gives life is also referred
to as breath I have a few verses here to
prove my point
in job 26 for example
job 26 and we read in verse 13. by his
Spirit he adorned the heavens his hand
pierced the fleeing serpent so the Holy
Spirit participated in creation
there is even a clear text in job 33
verse 4 and maybe Pastor you can read
Psalm 33 verse 6. that's right okay good
so job 33 verse verse 4
here it says the spirit of God has made
me and it uses the word and the breath
of the almighty gives me life
but who's the breath
is the spirit that gives life when the
Bible says he breaks into his nostrils
the Breath of Life what is this is
saying actually is the holy spirit
imparting life to that body of clay
um now Psalm 33 verse 6 again we see
there the Holy Spirit involved in the
work of creation yes
oh my Bible Pages are sticking Psalm 33
and verse
six
here we go Psalms 3 3 and verse 6 the
Bible says by the word of the Lord the
heavens were made and all the hosts of
them by the breath of his mouth
so again all the hosts of them by the
breath of his mouth Yes and he's using
their the same word one more Psalm 104
verses 29 and 30. uh you hide me you
hide your face there are trouble you
take away their breath yes they die and
return to their dust you send forth your
spirit so the parallelism there you send
forth your spirit they are created and
you renew the face of the earth now this
is true in creation but also in
Redemption yes yes yes yes because
Romans chapter 8 verse 11 it says
ratchet verse 2 says the spirit yes of
life in Christ Jesus has made me free
from the love sin and death and in verse
11 it says that uh that the holy spirit
that resurrected Jesus can also Quicken
our moral bodies through the spirit that
dwells in us so he can also recreate in
as a new heart he can Quicken our moral
bodies by sin and give us a new heart a
new mind yes make us a new creature in
Jesus Christ yes one is a spirit that
determines whether you're dead or alive
in the Physical Realm the other as
mentioned here is the spirit capital T
capital s that
determines whether you're dead or alive
in the spiritual realm it is the spirit
that quick enough that is a that is a
spiritual quickening
um
that makes you alive and acceptable uh
to the will and way and way of God
amen
alrighty thank you Brian
um for your question and um hopefully we
have done sufficient uh to your answer
maybe we can just squeeze in one more
yes that's an easy one this is Michael
uh this is the name we've seen before
so sometimes some people send us an
awful lot of questions and as we said we
don't throw any away we we try to get to
them all the live agents page 34. Ellen
White is including Daniel 244
with all the other prophecies listed on
this page
is Ellen White I'm sorry including
Daniel 2 44 with all the other
prophecies listed on this page as being
fulfilled in a very in a way that was
contrary to their expectations is it
possible that the glory of his reign
uh Ellen White is speaking of in desire
Ages page 34 the same glorious
ministration that Paul is speaking of in
second Corinthians chapter 3 verses 8
through 18. yeah
so I took my time to go to the reference
and we would we would highly encourage
our dear brother Michael Bruce that we
have received already several questions
from him and we really appreciate the
questions that you sent but it would be
easier for us if you could when you when
you called the spirit of Prophecy if you
could include the the quote so that we
can we can go quickly to to your
question to find it yes because
sometimes the page has several points
that we don't know exactly what
paragraph or what line you are referring
to in your question but I have to read
the whole page and and definitely Ellen
White there is talking about the
prophecies pointing to the coming of the
Messiah and then she quotes that that
Daniel 2 44 portrays the coming of a
better Kingdom that will Dash into
pieces of the kingdoms of the Earth but
that was not the way that the people
were or actually that was the way that
they were expecting the first coming of
the Messiah they were expecting Jesus as
coming as an Earthly King to to
establish an Earthly Kingdom and that's
why many of them were disappointed when
Jesus didn't do such a thing yes so
definitely yes I agree with you brother
that these prophecies were fulfilled in
a way that was contrary to their
expectations
now in regards to Second Corinthians 3
8-18 which we don't have time to read
the whole passage but Paul here is
talking about two glories the glory of
the old Covenant yeah and the glory of
the New Covenant the glory of the of the
old Covenant seeing in the face of Moses
the glory of the New Covenant seeing in
the face of Jesus
um so this is not talking about the
glory of an Earthly Kingdom this is
actually talking of the glory of the
Covenant the glory that is seen in the
face of Jesus Christ the righteousness
of God that's what this is talking about
amen amen well said
um
second Corinthians
uh chapter 3 verses 8 through 18. uh we
encourage you to read it all and again
Michael we thank you we get several
questions from Michael and uh as we
promise we don't toss any to the bottom
of the pile we answer them as they come
again our time has slipped away from us
um these half hour sessions go so
quickly uh we thank you so very much for
your participation for sending in
questions again we mentioned to you TV
at some tv.org
foreign
[Music]